to perform every Sunday the country's
dire economic crisis has made it
difficult for the renowned 77 year old
actor to find work elsewhere
we have never been like this it is what
generates a sadness on how the country
has impoverished us all
alarcon's pension is around a hundred
dollars a month and he relies on it to
make a living
but Argentina is struggling with a very
high inflation
in August the raid was more than 12
percent
this is a rich country a country that
can feed millions of people and still we
have millions who go hungry how can you
explain that no
Argentina's economy is a nice thing this
is the Peso currency and it's worth 50
percent less than it was six months ago
prices are soaring the government has
increased pensions and cash handouts but
for most people in this country it is
not enough
Argentina has a prominent film and
theater industry Luis Ali is a member of
the Argentine actors labor union he says
the industry has not been able to
recover since the pandemic
we haven't been able to go back to the
level of production we had before in
filmmaking ends in theaters this
economic crisis doesn't help it's
difficult to open new markets and
distribution chains there's many actors
who are struggling
country's High inflation rate is the
main issue in the next month's
presidential election far-right
candidate Javier melaye who has a real
chance of becoming Argentina's next
president is promising to cut public
spending and to dollarize the economy
he has been campaigning with a chainsaw
as a way of showing how he's gonna do it
against former security minister
Patricia Woolrich and ruling Pyrenees
party economy Chief Sergio Masa who is
calling for popular tax cuts for workers
I don't believe in Messianic discourses
like malaise I believe in democracy I
want a government that's controlled by
Congress and not by decree
whoever wins the presidency will have to
deal with difficult economic scenarios
and the millions of argentines who are
doing everything they can to survive
there is
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera